et en direct est devenu le maître jean
marc florand c'est donc vous qui allait
faire appel dès demain leurs premières
questions très concrètes avez vous
rencontré patrick dils depuis son retour
en prison
est-ce lui qui seul à décider de cette
nouvelle comparution avez vous tenté de
le convaincre de le dissuader
vous êtes vous contenter de l'écouter
alors j'ai rencontré longuement patrick
dils après le verdict rendu par la cour
d'assises de la marne vendredi très tard
dans la nuit et nous a dit très
concrètement qu'il voulait continuer à
se battre et qu'il laissait à ses deux
avocats maître becker et moi même
le choix des armes donc après en avoir
décidé avec ses parents et en accord et
qu'on confrères becker nous avons décidé
de faire appel dès demain de l'arrêt
rendu par la cour d'assises de la marne
alors on a un peu le sentiment que les
décisions se joue davantage entre la
famille de patrick dils et ses avocats
est ce à dire qu'il n'est pas tout à
fait apte à maîtriser son destin ou est
ce que c'est une fausse impression d'un
ou non il est tout à fait il est tout à
fait apte à maîtriser son destin
simplement il ne maîtrise pas toutes les
questions juridiques extrêmement
complexe de ce dossier qui est une
première dans les annales judiciaires
françaises et nous a laissé le choix des
voies de recours qui nous paraissaient
les plus aptes à sauver son honneur
alors question encore très concrète est
ce que vous avez conscience qu'il y a
peut-être un certain risque à entamer un
troisième procès par exemple sur quelles
bases pouvez-vous dire qu'il aura lieu
par exemple dès l'automne alors ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce procès aura lieu
d'ici moins d'un an puisque les
différentes affaires comparables où il
ya eu un appel dans l'arrêt d'assises
ont été ré audience et dans les six mois
ou dans les huit mois pour que nous
pouvons espérer que d'ici et le
printemps 2002 cette affaire sera rejugé
par une autre cour d'assises dans un
autre département
nous avons c'est l'idée qu'il puisse
comparaître libre pour ce nouveau procès
c'était une conviction ou une
démonstration qui est en fait pourrait
s'avérer aléatoire si vous savez bien
que certaines ambiguïtés dans les
lectures du droit est précisément de la
nouvelle loi
c'est une certitude on ce que l'
ordonnance de 1945 qui régit le droit
des mineurs la justice des mineurs
prévoit qu'un mineur ne peut pas le
placer plus de deux en détention
provisoire
or il a été très précisément du 30 avril
1987 au 23 janvier 1989 il est de
nouveau en détention provisoire depuis
le 3 avril 2001 donc il devrait être
libéré automatiquement dans les pieds
alors vous évoquez
la création d'un comité de soutien où
vous voulez faire appel à l'opinion
publique avec quelle personnalité pour
et dans quel but au fond l'idée si vous
voulez très simple patrick dils est
parfaitement innocents du double crime
qu'on lui impute à montigny-lès-metz en
1986 ce n'est pas uniquement la
conviction de la défense mais je vous
rappelle que c'est également la
conviction du représentant du ministère
public puisque l'avocat général au
procès de reims monsieur sarcelet a
réclamé l'acquittement après avoir
démontré pourquoi par a plus b deal
c'est innocent du double crime de
montigny à partir de là si la justice ne
veut pas entendre cette innocence alors
même que le parquet général chargé de
l'accusation réclame cette innocence par
un acquittement
je crois qu'il est nécessaire d'en
appeler à l'opinion publique et de faire
comme ça a été le cas dans certains cas
historiques célèbres appelle un comité
national de justice pour dire comme ça a
pu l'être pour dreyfus ou pour d'autres
condamnés moins célèbres merci m d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions